thank you everyone for joining me for
the very last session of NDC Sydney if
you all had a good week yep you're all
exhausted so I got one like tie-in yep
and the rest were little lazily knotted
heads I will just point out one more
thing there is an event after this it's
not related to in DC Sydney it's not
official called pub Kampf if you wanted
to come along PubCon io and there might
be a ticket or two left and by I
literally mean like one or two tickets
left
so I'm give it a look if you're
interested in that alright so my name is
Damian Brady I work for Microsoft I work
out of Australia essentially work from
home as a cloud developer advocate which
basically means my job is to advocate
both for Microsoft for our cloud yeah
Asia but also to advocate for the
community and one of the reasons that
I'm interested in this kind of idea of
the process of data science is because
being perfectly honest I don't think
right now we do a good job of this and
in fact I don't think anybody does a
great job of this right my expertise is
in DevOps but I've started getting
interested in things like machine
learning and data science and so on as
well
and this is something that I've been
focusing on a lot now right up front I'm
gonna give you a little bit of a Worman
warning this talk is like maximum buzz
word
there's DevOps in it there's machine
learning there's that data science it's
if I had blockchain in it you just had
was a heads would explode all right I'm
not gonna talk about blockchain but I am
gonna say I'm gonna try and step away
from the buzzword e stuff and talk a
little bit more about practical ways
that I think the stuff that I do with
DevOps and we talked about with DevOps
can help when it comes to a data science
process I'm just I'm sorry I'm going to
get off that slide just um it's giving
me a headache just so I know who's in
here can I just ask who would consider
themselves more of a developer or
operations person so along that side of
this - - pipe system okay that's most
people that's good anybody who would
consider themselves first and foremost a
data scientist
okay nice all right so it's mainly
developers which you'd probably expect
at a developer conference and that's
kind of where I come from as well I've
been a developer for nearly 20 years a
professional developer for nearly 20
years but I wrote my first first line of
code when I was 10 so I've been doing
that for a little while
data science though is really pretty new
to me and I remember looking at it when
I was when I was at university I'd saw
some projects that were really
interesting and really cool and I asked
what it would take to you know write the
neural network that somebody had written
and was yes people he started talking
about you know deep dense trees and like
forests and asked me how am I like
multi-dimensional calculus was and so I
backed well away from that because I was
not good at that stuff I did one subject
at university that had calculus in it I
did it by accident because the person
who was telling me what subjects I
needed to do gave me the wrong subject
code I got a I got a three in that which
was technically a path so I didn't have
to do it again so this idea of these two
different fields like I do a lot of
stuff with DevOps but then there's this
data science part as well these are
really quite often two different worlds
so what I'm trying to focus on is how
there's a bit of overlap between the two
the two fields and what does that
overlap look like like how can these two
fields influence either each other and
especially coming from a DevOps
perspective how can we use some of those
techniques to to build in the process or
to assist the process when it comes to
data science because more and more the
outcomes of data scientists are data
science predictive models and things
like that are being embedded in our
applications like if you wanted some way
of doing handwriting recognition or like
predicting whether somebody is going to
default on a loan you've just given them
if you wanted that in your software
twenty thirty years ago it would have
been really difficult to do no you would
have needed your own Department of data
scientists to work that stuff out and it
would be a difficult thing now it's a
service on a show like you throw it some
data and get a predictive model out the
other end and if you're happy with it
you included in your application so
we've kind of got to this stage of
commoditization of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning but putting that into the
developer process is something that's
just not really happening at the moment
so I want to look at what this area is
now as I said I know I feel like I know
my stuff when it comes to DevOps I mean
this team of League of Clare the League
of Extraordinary cloud DevOps advocates
that we nicknamed ourselves it just
rolls off the tongue I have I'm on
podcast every now and then talking about
DevOps I have a channel 9 show on
Microsoft I called the DevOps lab so I
kind of feel like I know my stuff with
DevOps but then when it comes to the
data science stuff not not so much so if
you put me on a scale of stuff that I
know with data scientists data science
and kind of below the Year stage of that
but thankfully working for Microsoft you
get the opportunity to speak to like a
ton of people who do know about data
scientists there are data science so
that's just a handful of people I've
spoken to in the last few months about
this topic specifically so I can
leverage some of their knowledge as well
and that's really really helped so what
does this overlap look like right what
are we actually trying to achieve and
let's start on the left here let's start
with DevOps what does DevOps actually
mean so this is our definition of DevOps
and Microsoft the union of people
processed products and to enable
continuous delivery of value to our
end-users the idea really being that
you're focusing on the value that you're
delivering to people and you're focusing
not just on the product itself that you
use to do all of this stuff like your
source control and your as a DevOps or
your whatever tools you use you're
focusing on the process and being able
to push this value out into production
and work out whether it is valuable or
not kind of the idea is to do this fast
and sustainably so that you can push
smaller pieces out to production quicker
and get feedback on those really really
fast so this is kind of what it's about
there's a really really good report that
comes out every year called the state of
DevOps report I would highly highly
recommend you have a look at it the
basic summary of the state of DevOps
report and there'll be a link in a slide
in a second as well if you're taking a
photo just out of interest the crux of
it is this for kind of
four kinds of metrics that you want to
focus on when it comes to DevOps this
deployment frequency time to restore
service lead time for changes and change
failure rate and the summary of the
summary is really that teams that do
this stuff well do it way better than
teams who don't do it well and in fact a
gap between the people who are doing it
well and the teams that are not doing it
well is widening which is a bit of an
issue so as an example people who do
DevOps well can deploy their stuff 46
times faster than people who do it badly
right time to restore service if
something goes down elite performers as
classified by the the cluster analysis
in this report elite performers two and
a half thousand times faster at
restoring service when something goes
wrong that seems like a ludicrous number
right but if you think about the the
teams that do this the worst when
something goes down there is so much
process in the way of fixing that
problem that it might take them a few
seconds to break the thing but it's
going to take them six months to get
everything back up and running so this
is these are legitimate numbers and
there is a lot of academic research in
this report this is not just somebody
doing a whole bunch of Survey Monkey
things and then saying hey here's what
it is there's 30,000 data points it's
published in journal articles there's
there's really really rigorous analysis
behind this stuff so you can take the
stuff to the bank that is the link there
I just they just created one just a
bitly
short link 2018 DevOps report but if you
search for this state of DevOps report
it's really really yeah it's accessible
and it's around over all the time at the
moment I could talk about that report
itself for a four-day workshop it's
there's so much great information in
that and it doesn't matter what industry
you're in this stuff holds when it comes
to - I'm actually delivering value to
production so that's kind of why you
want to do it is proven in these reports
and it means getting stuff out faster
and focusing what's temperate what's on
in production let's kind of just
simplify the process that you go through
I'm in DevOps and this is my super
simple site
of a DevOps process you do your planning
and your tracking so that what work are
we doing and how's that work going you
develop that code or you make those
changes you test it you make sure that's
all right you create builds and test
those builds and make sure they're all
right and then you deploy it out to
production and then you watch what's
happening in production not just am I
getting exceptions but our people using
this feature the way that I expected
them to or do people hate this feature
and we shouldn't do any more work on it
and then you put that information back
into your planning and tracking and you
iterate as fast as you can around this
cycle while maintaining stability one of
the other things that came out of that
accelerate report was that these things
move in tandem so stability and speed
actually move in tandem in organizations
that do things well which is
counterintuitive sometimes especially in
organizations where they're like no we
need months and months to test this
thing so nothing goes wrong in
organizations that deploy really really
frequently they the quality actually
just goes up because each time they
deploy something the blast radius is
smaller so this is kind of the idea you
put processes in place so that you can
cycle through this really really quickly
work out what stuff is useful and what
stuff isn't and iterate really quickly
pivot on the stuff that's useful so
that's kind of how the DevOps stuff
works and we're talking about software
development here right working out what
you're gonna put in production putting
it there and monitoring it
data science again not my core field
this was the best definition that I
found or the one that resonated the most
with me and there's a lot of words on
the screen so I'm just gonna have a
drink and let you read them and then
I'll highlight my highlights of the
so the the general summary of this is
that it's a super broad field right
projects in data science can be anything
from hey we've got a sequel database
here can you just have a look and tell
me what the average amount of money
we're spending on this thing is as like
a once-off that could technically be a
data science process that progress
project
let's go project or it could be building
a really deep neural network using
streaming data from something to do
real-time predictions of what people
need to do next in a finance application
or something like that it you know these
things are very very different projects
but they're still they still come under
data science and it's not just the
process there's theories of data science
there's different models there's
convolutional neural networks there's
all the different parts of these
networks and and all of that kind of
stuff
is all part of this big field of data
science the end goal of this though is
to be able to extract knowledge from
data so that you can make better
decisions from a business point of view
so that first example of how much we're
spending on this particular item there's
a reason that somebody wants to know
that they want to know how much we spend
on this particular thing in our business
so that we can plan for the future the
neural network that you build that does
predictive analysis of whether somebody
is going to break their loan or you know
stop buying your service or something
based on this really really deep complex
network the answer to that is going to
drive business behavior it is what do we
do if we think somebody is going to
cancel our service or what do we do if
we think somebody is going to default on
their loan that's really what it is
yeah data you squish that data into
something and you get an answer at the
other end or a model that's going to
give you a prediction at the other end
that's my take on it right on what data
science is and again - totally simplify
the process this is what usually happens
there is a phase of acquisition of data
and understanding of what is required
and understanding that data there's a
preparation phase of the data to say
this is what the data looks like but we
need to change it
it looks like you know this it's in this
form so we can operate on it so for
example you might have three text fields
that somebody's put in a database
somewhere and you want to extract the
most you know commonly used words or
that's one way that you might prepare it
and then based on that you can create a
model that describes that data and can
help you make predictions you might look
at that model and say well that's
actually not describing the data it's
not helping me at all and so you go
around this loop of acquiring data
understanding the data preparing it and
then creating these models at some point
you deploy this model out to production
and that literally deploying to
production could be printing a report
and putting it on your managers desk and
then it's in production right or it
could be to play it in a docker
container to a production system so that
your web application can call that
service you know it there's a lot of
different variation on that as well
quite often though that last little
arrow going from deploy and evaluate
back to acquisition and understanding
sometimes that doesn't exist that arrow
so this is a cycle and this is what
we're familiar with in computer science
it's not necessarily the way that data
science works that might just be a
once-off project or that arrow any
occurs once a year they only want that
number once a year so there's a
difference there as well there's a lot
of focus endeavors for data science
around the actual deployment so
container izing your your model or
putting it in a portable format and then
importing it into an application so
operationalizing it but I think there's
a lot of value to be added by DevOps in
this cycle here doing the work that
actually produces the models and
iterating around that so you're not
repeating work so much now I mentioned
before that there's there's not as many
like formal processes we have tons of
formal processes for software
development and we've been through
various iterations of you know waterfall
and agile and XP and scrum and all that
kind of stuff as well there's a lot of
formal stuff that we do in dirt in
computer science but not I said there's
not so much in data science and it's not
actually true when I went to verify this
I found a whole bunch of formal data
science
so knowledge discovery in databases or
kdd is one crisp dm's one the
cookie-cutter data science template is
one and then there's one from Microsoft
which was pointed to me by lace right
when I spoke to you about it she was one
of the icons on the ya-ya graph of how
much people know so the team science
data process is a thing that Microsoft
develops about how we do data science
projects right and it's a template and a
series of rules and things like that
it's basically splits your data science
process into a series of phases which is
really similar to what I was talking
about before in that cycle there's a
business understanding so what exactly
do we need to do what are we trying to
solve here data acquisition and
understanding the data creating models
deploying them and then the customer
acceptance stuff of we've completed this
project it's it's good to go
now for me this is a little bit
waterfall II it's a bit more it's a it
seems to me a bit more like okay here's
this but here's the requirements
document he's a specification here is
your code deploy it to production and
everybody signs off and everything's
alright but I'm coming from a from a
computer science perspective right so I
look at this and I think that seems like
waterfall right if you look at the
detail it's not quite like that I mean
there's there's actually a lot of detail
in this document and I'll put a link up
to that document soon as well actually I
think I put it up at the end so there is
a lot of stuff in there there's
templates
there's tooling there's some awesome
stuff in that team science data data
process I would strongly recommend you
go and have a look at that too so there
are these life cycles for these these
two different fields computer science or
you know stuff that we do with DevOps
and data science and this is this middle
bit is kind of what we want to see but
we noticed there's a bit of difference
between what we do with computer science
is very iterative and like you you go
through deploying tiny little increments
of bits of code and you build up this
application where as a data science
project might have a single model at the
other end and you do it once and you
don't do it again for another year
so is there kind of an overlap between
is
all are these two totally different
fields and that's not it's not actually
universally accepted that day is an
overlap there was a really interesting
tweet where somebody tweeted about a
session that they went to with Jeremy
Howard who I don't really know but this
tweet was very interesting too saying
data science code doesn't need to follow
rules of good software engineering
because it's not about creating software
it's about experimenting and building
prototypes and models right so in other
words hey it's an experimental thing you
you look at data and then you create a
model at the other end and it doesn't
need to follow a good software
development practices it's a totally
different field now in fairness that was
kind of a misquote and so Jeremy Howard
actually came back and said to look to
clarify you still have to follow rules
and they're different but they're pretty
overlapping or they're partly
overlapping with software engineering so
in other words if you're a software
developer try to learn from data science
and and vice-versa as well so it's not
completely clear that there is this
really clear overlap but coming from a
DevOps perspective and looking at what
these data science projects do I really
feel like there's a lot of stuff in in
DevOps that can be applied to data
science really nicely alright so there's
a few things I think you need to care
about as a developer trying to tell data
scientists how to do their job right and
I think the animations have gone weird
here but there is languages and tools so
the languages and tools that we use as
developers are going to be different to
tools and the languages that data
scientists use I spoke to somebody a
while ago about you know how we at
Microsoft recommend people do their you
know their are their neural network
trainings and things like that and I
said well you just write your Python in
Visual Studio I'm like nope there's been
like you're not going to do that if
somebody told you like let's say you
write c-sharp if somebody said oh no
we're actually gonna write c-sharp now
in Eclipse or something just go do that
you're not going to be as productive
because that's not the tool you use so
we don't want to replace the tools the
data scientists
use and we don't want to get them to
start writing c-sharp if they've written
path Python or arc for their whole
careers all right so maintaining the
languages and tools and building on top
of those there is a lot of
experimentation that goes on in data
science all right so you might have a
theory about how this data fits together
and how a model might be created you
might think it's it's going to be
explained by this particular model
function and you just need to do some
training with a neural network that
looks like this and all that sort of
stuff so you run experiment and maybe
they succeed and maybe they don't it's
very much a science but it's
experimentation based right so you
really need to take into account the
fact that there are experiments that you
need to run as a matter of course in
data science you can almost think of it
like extreme spiking like if you're a
developer and you do spiking where
you're like I'm using a new component
let me just try this for a bit and see
if it works okay that's probably going
to end up solving the problem that I
want it to solve let's put it back in
the real application right it's it's
that a little bit more extreme right it
might happen all the time
so experiments are definitely something
that you need to take take care of the
other aspect with this as well is it's
really important that you keep track of
those experiments so very much the same
as you have source control so you so
other people can look back and see what
you did or documentation so other people
can look back and see what you did it's
really useful for a new data scientist
coming in to be able to look at a
previous experiment and say oh okay they
tried that and it didn't produce the
result they wanted so that's really
important as well and the other thing is
and I mentioned this is the life cycles
are very different we really push in
DevOps terms now that you treat your
project a bit more like a product where
you do small iterations and you cycle
really really quickly you may not be
doing that in a data science project you
may be doing it once and never doing it
again
so you need to be cognizant of that
building an entire full pipeline to do
everything in a deployment when you're
doing a once-off query to generate a
word document don't don't you don't need
to do it right so in some cases you
can't you don't need to do
and then finally you need to work out
whether there's some kind of
traceability or explained ability and
this can be sometimes be hard in
especially machine learning stuff
sometimes your project requires that you
need to be able to explain how you came
up with the model that you have
especially if you're operating in Europe
for example if you used a ton of
customer data to come up with a
predictive model you need to be able to
explain what data you used and how your
model came up with the predictions that
it came up with that means that you need
to be able to trace exactly what you did
to get this model at the other end so
even though the process or even though
data science projects are a bit
different it's still not acceptable in
most cases for a data scientist to do
some work on their machine and say ah
here you go here's a here's a predictive
model he's a pickle file that I gave you
like you need to be able to trace what
they did you need to be able to find out
what happened to get to that point it's
a little bit like the the developer
sitting in the basement of a you know
old-school company and the code only
exists on his hard drive or her hard
drive and they write all their code and
they pull out the DLL at the end of it
and then there you go alright you can't
do that anymore
so similar kind of thing um one thing as
well when we talk about data for sorry
DevOps for data science is people quite
often focus on the operationalization I
say our DevOps yeah that's where you
take the output and you put it in a
docker container we can do that we can
help with that process I think there's a
lot more that you can do here so I'm
gonna run through a number of practices
that that are really common in software
development and in DevOps that I think
can be applied very largely to data
science projects and I'm not I don't
want to be prescriptive about so here is
exactly what you should do right these
are things that I want you to think
about that you can take from DevOps and
bring in to data science projects so the
first thing is source control right it
is just if you run into a company now
that he's not using source control that
is a real anomaly at the moment however
there's a lot of data scientist data
science projects where
the source code is somebody's bunch of
queries in a folder on their in their
documents like it's not always common
for somebody to have all this stuff in
source control and it is really
important whether it's git and you're
forcing the data scientists to use git
or whether it's just the tools that they
use having some kind of history of what
they've done history of experiments
they've run history of the code they've
got the changes they've made and some
way of actually having a canonical piece
of information saying this is what we
did at a particular time right if your
data scientists are not developers and
that is most of the time then they're
not going to understand when you say no
we need you to put everything in a git
repo right the fact that you need to
keep a history though shouldn't take
away from that
so think about having histories of what
what you've done and the code that you
use to produce these predictive models
sometimes as well when we when we're
doing this work so the ETL phase or the
data acquisition and transformation and
all that kind of stuff and that stuff
gets shipped shipped aside so somebody
will say oh there's my real data set but
to do some training I need to tweak it
this way I'm gonna tweak a bunch of it
I'm gonna take an extract of it and I'm
gonna create this new data base I'll
change this field I'll change those ones
I'll remove these these extra records
that are outliers okay oh here's the
data that I'm using now but that process
of getting from the canonical data to
the what the data that you're going to
use to create your model that whole
process needs to be codified it needs to
be in some kind of some kind of system
that acknowledges that this is what you
have done so source control is a great
way of doing that but don't force your
other scientists to use git or something
like that try and get the tooling that
does that work for you something that we
do in software development a lot is
refactoring so this actually helps with
DevOps a lot if you can make a change to
your code such that it's easier for you
to make subsequent changes then it means
you can move faster right if you can
change the way that your data is stored
such that it makes it easier to query
things later
that's maybe a worthwhile endeavor right
so if your data is just stored in a like
as a series of documents just sitting in
a folder somewhere on a on a data server
in your environment maybe the
application that's writing those logs
are writing that data could publish to
some kind of event stream and then you
could store that data in a different
database that contains everything but in
a format that is going to be useful for
you later on so refactoring the way that
you have are storing your data can be
really valuable
there's projects as well where you need
to make sure that you can revisit what
the state of the data was at a
particular time so if you have if you
have data that can change that you can
update maybe that's not actually
appropriate for your data science
process a project now you might end up
with a predictive model and when they
say how did you get this model here
don't really know because the data
doesn't exist anymore it's been changed
since then so refactoring to maybe
change the way your data is stored can
be really handy as well another thing
you can get from devops the DevOps
process is we talked about
infrastructure as code so not only are
we storing the the code that does the
work but we're also storing code that
defines the environment that that code
runs on now in data science terms you
might need to do your training on a
particular machine or a particular
configuration with certain versions of
your Python dependencies and things like
that if you can codify this it means
that the developer who is doing the
training while they're experimenting
with things while they're exploring the
data they are using the same system that
you can use to train on your petabytes
of data later on to produce that model
file it means when a new developer comes
in if you can just say here is the
standard like training machine that we
are using they can just start using it
if you have defined this stuff in code
or at least defined it in a particular
way and this is quite often overlooked
as well you know data scientists will
have their machine which has all of
their libraries in it and they do their
training
and they produced their model file but
if somebody new comes in they can't
really do that work because they're not
on the same machine and these are
problems that we've seen in computer
science for years and years as well so
having a definition of what these
machines look like and what these
dependencies look like is really
important too
Automation is a big one as well and this
again depends on that life cycle we were
talking about automation is one of those
things where you speak to somebody who's
been doing DevOps for a little while and
they're like yeah that's where we build
a pipeline that does everything for us
which is great but that's not the end
goal right the end goal is to be able to
make changes and make sure they're okay
and pushed them into production if they
are an experiment and be able to change
things and and have that cycle that life
cycle all right so automation for things
that you do more than once is really
handy and can be really handy whether
you're writing code and deploying it to
production or whether you're running
experiments for example so if you wanted
to do if you wanted to train your model
using a bunch of different things and
you have very similar data that comes in
each time redoing those same tasks every
single time might be something you can
automate there's a really cool xkcd
comic there's always an xkcd comic which
is basically just says over five years
here's how much time you have to you
have to spend before you start saving
time again so just to summarize let's
say you you do a task weekly and it
saves you a minute each time you know
this doing this automation will save you
a minute
you can spend four hours on that thing
and get your time back and so this is
like a funny kind of joke right but this
is serious like if you can automate
something and you do it every single day
and by automating it you save an hour
you can spend 10 months on this project
like to automate that thing and you will
make your money you'll make your time
back in five years so if you do the same
thing more than once maybe consider
whether you can automate it if you can
automate everything that happens in a
repeated process then it's going to save
you
a lot of time so this can apply not just
to computer science and things like that
it's completely applied to data science
projects too we talked about in DevOps
as well things like continuous
integration continuous deployment
continuous testing so continuous
integration is really just where you
take your code and everybody else's code
and you put it together and you make
sure it still compiles and it passes all
your tests and things like that but you
do that on a continuous basis in other
words you're not writing code that sits
completely isolated from everybody
else's code and then one day in three
months time you try to merge it and
realize that stuff doesn't work anymore
right
this is directly a little less
appropriate or less applicable to data
science I think but you do have
potentially lots of data scientists
working on the same problem so having a
way of continuously running your
training or running your tests and doing
that kind of stuff in a pipeline that
doesn't require these develop these I'm
data scientist to sit there and talk
about talk to each other about oh hey
I'm doing this now and is that going to
affect what you're what you're doing
having this continuous process where
this stuff happens automatically can be
valuable it comes into effect even more
when you talk about continuous testing
so in other words when you're building
this stuff up are you monitoring the the
scoring that comes out of these trained
models are you cutting this stuff off
early if it's not working right are you
running tests against not just the the
training and the produced models but are
you running tests that test for like
edge cases if you trained a model in
there's like a log that comes out
somewhere in the middle of all of these
calculations in your model that you've
created and you've only ever given it
positive values are you tough are you
testing the edge case where somebody
inputs a negative value all right you
can test your code it's it's Python it's
R it's whatever you want to use you can
still test that and that means writing
that code in a way that is testable
running those tests every single time
you make a change to your model training
can be really handy as well just to make
sure you haven't inexplicably introduced
a bug that you didn't expect
right so continuous testing can apply
as well and of course we get to the
operationalization of it which is
continuous delivery where we've created
this model or we've we've created this
way of creating a model we got to model
out the other end and then what do we do
with that model a docker seems to be
what people have landed on lately
especially for operationalization
operationalizing this stuff so you
create a model you wrap it in a basic
API and deploy that as a docker
container that has a lot of really big
advantages one is that that container is
an artifact or that image is an artifact
which represents not just the model the
predictive model that you've created but
it's also this portable thing that you
can move to somewhere else to either try
it out on a new application try it out
on a new hardware run it on a drone I
don't know if you've seen like those DJI
drones that can run docker containers
that's amazing right if you have some
kind of vision analysis that you've
created and you can run that docker
container on a drone and because you've
built this pipeline you can maybe tweak
and improve that vision sorry this
vision model that you've created run it
through that pipeline it creates a
docker container out the other end and
you can push it up to the to the drone
and that's fantastic um you can also use
continuous delivery techniques to do
things like a be test predictive models
so you could have a cluster of docker
images which just contain this
self-contained model this predictive
model that you have and then you point
some of your application instances to
the new version of it and you check the
scores you monitor it you continuously
monitor what's happening in production
and work out whether it's performing
better or whether it's not which kind of
leads to production monitoring can you
actually look at what a model is doing
and determine whether it is successful
or not whether it's improving or whether
it's getting stale potentially so you
could deploy a predictive model that
tells that your application uses to tell
people whether or to tell people what
movie predictions or what movies they
may like based on the things that
you know the Netflix style of thing
right can you look at what people are
doing with the output of that model to
tell you whether that model is
successful or not and this could be a
hard problem right one way I can think
of to do that is you actually a be test
your different models and you look at
funnels like our people clicking on
their recommendations more or less with
this new model that we've deployed if
it's more than maybe we roll that out a
little bit further so these kind of
techniques can be applied to to data
science projects as well one thing I'll
mention as well is that these two things
so data science project where you create
a predictive model at the other end or
something that's going to tell you some
information that you want to direct your
business and the software that might
potentially use this model now these two
parallel activities are often done in a
really disconnected way and I don't
think that's necessarily a problem right
the cadence is going to be totally
different your developers might be
updating your Netflix style website 20
times a day
you're not going to rebuild a model 20
times a day to do that stuff it might be
three or four times a week but where it
does come together is where the
application needs to work out what model
to use so there's a lot of techniques
you can use and simply having an
artifact of the current model the data
scientists have produced and having that
as part of your build pipeline with your
application or part of your deployment
pipeline with your application it can be
really valuable say I'm deploying a new
version of the application what is the
current predictive model that my data
scientists have said is the the best one
right now pull that down to play with
the application so this kind of stuff
can be done now as for tooling like I
said it's not fantastic at the moment
there's nothing great that does this
work
right now I don't think everything that
I've seen has has gaps that may change
soon we doing some things and there's a
conference next week in Orlando I think
so stay tuned for stuff but this idea of
having this process that can be tracked
experiments tracked models produced
operationalized and used as part of your
pipelines is something that we are
definitely focusing on so I've kind of
kind of just talked a lot right at this
point I want to summarize kind of the
highlights of what I think you should be
looking at if you're trying to get some
DevOps processes into your data science
projects so number one actually there's
two pages of this so my summary is less
of a summary it's it has more words than
the titles that I had but here's kind of
the outcome of it so keep everything in
source control and it doesn't have to be
source control source control don't you
don't need to teach your data scientists
to use get like I'm a developer I can
barely use get right I know for commands
and if it doesn't work after there's
four commands I go to stack overflow or
oh get comm which is fantastic by
the way or I speak to this guy so you
need to be able to keep everything in
source control so you can see what
you've done and you need to be able to
allow for experimentation so doing
things like requiring your data
scientists to create a new branch every
time they do an experiment if they're
explicitly having to go to get and
create a new branch and do that kind of
stuff
they're not going to do it I barely do
that stuff right
most of my get most of my get process is
crew doing a whole lot of changes and
then committing them and going oh no my
master all right let's create a new
branch and put the changes in that one
and then submit a pull request so and
I'm a developer telling your data
scientists to create a new branch every
time you do an experiment it's not
really going to work but you need to
allow for that because that's part of
the process using canonical data sources
is really important so that example I
gave of pulling everything down from the
real data base tweaking it yourself and
then having your own little data base
that you train on as a data scientist
not not appropriate right you need some
way of saying this is the real data that
we are we're training on and it may not
be the production data base it may be an
extract of the production database that
you do on a regular basis it may be
streams data that's built
so you're not getting any personally
identifiable information but you need to
be able to say that is the data that my
models are trained on that is the data
that we are using as our for the
creation of our predictive models all
right so don't let the data scientists
have their own special little database
that they're not really sure how they
got or you know a dump of of something
they did three months ago all right a
canonical data source to say this is
what we use is really important
especially when you build up pipelines
don't be read it don't be afraid to
refactor how that data is stored - it
may not be able to change what's in
production but maybe you can add a
stream some kind of streaming to it so
you can store it in your own in your own
way I'm standardizing your environments
in code and defining those in code make
it really easy not just to kick off the
new training sessions or new experiments
but also for new data scientists who
come in they have all of the stuff that
you need immediately to do their work
really effectively and this is something
we do in computer science a lot automate
wisely and don't just assume that
everything because we automate
everything in data science so in
computer science that you're going to
want to automate everything in data
science if you do it more than once
definitely look at it but if it's a
once-off report you don't have to with
force this stuff every time I don't
think and then pipelines can be really
useful for repeatability and being able
to explain what you did to get to a
particular stage and if you're saving
artifacts at the end of each of those
you can say well we did this here's what
we ran through this was the build
process or the training process the
scoring and here's our model out the
other end and when we abandoned that
because we didn't think it was good
enough right but that process means that
you can repeat it over and over again
this pipeline and explain what you did
each time and deploying portable models
is some advice from Paige Bailey who
works for Microsoft she is really really
strongly of the opinion that you
shouldn't be writing a model for that
specific purpose write the model the
predictive model and then wrap it in
something which makes it portable right
so a portable model is not an Excel
spreadsheet which has the answers to the
12 questions that you're that your boss
asked you it's a it's a model that you
can query to
give you an answer whenever you feel
like it and you might want to query it
from a web application right now but in
three months maybe you want to open that
up to a phone application that somebody
is using as well right so having a
portable model is easy to do and
definitely worthwhile and then testing
your models continuously and monitoring
what's happening in production so that
they don't get stale and having a data
refresh strategy in a training refresh
strategy is important as well
one other thing that we talk about a lot
in DevOps that I haven't mentioned here
is this concept of shift left so the
idea with shift left is if you can
discover a problem earlier in your life
cycle or earlier on when you're doing
the work it is far cheaper to fix it
then than it is when it's in production
and so if there is a problem with this
process this data science process and
you can fix that problem earlier by for
example standardized in your environment
and meaning that everybody is using
exactly the same machines to train their
their models that is an easier problem
to fix right upfront than trying to work
out why this person's model looks
totally different than this person's
model when they should have done the
same thing right so keeping this in the
back of your mind is really handy as
well shifting left a couple of resources
as well in a it's a bit of Inception but
that is a link to the slides that I'm
showing right now if you wanted to have
a look at some of those as well they're
not great Slayers they're me drawing but
you know it might remind you of some of
the stuff that I've I've looked at and
that team data science process document
is up there as well I would also highly
encourage you to keep an eye on ignite
next week in Orlando for data science
process and AI stuff as well all I'm
allowed to say on that so I think I'm a
little bit early so I have plenty of
time for questions I think but other
than that thank you very much
so questions cuz I have I have question
yes I was just curious what your view on
notebooks fits into so I think everybody
can hear cousin Mike but I'll just
repeat it anyway because that's habit my
view on Jupiter notebooks and how that
fits into DevOps so when I when I first
saw Jupiter notebooks I was like this
thing's amazing so for those who aren't
familiar with it it's basically it is
always Python yeah no nope oh sorry okay
so you can just fish up in Jupiter
notebooks alright I know what I'm doing
tomorrow but basically the idea is you
have the code that you're doing that's
doing the work and then you have
markdown or you have some kind of
description of what you're doing like
above it and so the best examples of
Jupiter notebooks might be okay I'm you
know I'm gonna get this data from this
particular database it contains this
information and we're just going to
analyze it to see what it looks like you
know scatter plot just to give an idea
of whatever and then you have the code
that does it and then the output that
comes out of that and you can see what
it does and so you're basically walking
through the process you did as an
exploration of that data or as a
transformation of that data and things
like that so the first time I saw
Jupiter notebooks I'm like this is
amazing it's like documentation
alongside the code and then alongside
the output and it's fantastic all you
need to do is do all your work in those
Jupiter notebooks and then version them
in source control and then everybody you
know can just can just get going
the difficulty I've seen since is that a
it's really hard to version control that
because it's I believe it's like a
massive chunk of Jason under the covers
or something Jason something like that
yeah yeah yeah
but that's like complaint number one but
I have a few more so actually you can
version control and notebooks notebooks
are Python notebooks would be sorry
Jupiter notebooks would be a a text file
the problem is each of those cells
you're talking about that you're
stepping through it's kind of wrapped in
some kind of weird markup thing right
okay however if you look at data breach
data breaks is an actually product that
does its really really well and it you
can hook up your get to run your
notebooks and version control so whoever
worse if you're 10 if your team works on
those notebooks they can they can do
even diff that doesn't bring you to this
ugly right ugly notation and another
benefit especially of data breaks is
that you can take a notebook and run it
you know as a badge without looking all
this and treat it literally like a like
a batch file for for your cluster okay
thanks
is that is that data break starter mix
or Azure data bricks same thing okay so
when I've looked at the source control
stuff for data breaks I've seen it use
github or bitbucket is that as long as
it's get is what I've been told
okay um so yeah that can work with the
source control stuff um often GP
notebooks are just somebody's running
stuff on their machine but yes I
definitely take the point um there's
other things like if you can run the
cells out of order and you can like you
can work with these things and it just
doesn't give you what you expect and
it's a bit unpredictable and things like
that the other bigger one for me though
is operationalizing that so you can you
put your jupiter notebook in production
and you probably can but should you is
it testable as well like if you do these
five steps to get your data in a
particular format how do you test that
step three is a is a function that does
what you're supposed to do and so from a
computer science perspective a software
development perspective at second glance
it just didn't seem quite as nice I mean
the Python is what you care about and
yes absolutely use Jupiter notebooks to
to do your experimentation
and your analysis and your all of that
kind of stuff that's great but when it
comes to something that you need to put
in a pipeline to get a model at the
other end on a repeated basis I would
really prefer to see the Python
extracted into like actual Python
modules and and things like that that
you can call externally and you can do
that stuff with Python with um achieved
in notebooks as well kind some of it
this sounds like a long discussion yeah
sorry not a question but at the last
Jupiter con there was actually good talk
about why I hate notebooks yes which was
really really good and there was a huge
Twitter storm after it so I recommend
looking that up and looking at the
comments that follow so did that that
talk actually is is or the the slide
deck somebody sent me that and that was
where I was like before I saw that slide
deck I'm like yeah even notebooks are
amazing and then I saw the slide deck
and I'm like yeah you know that's that's
probably right I mean ultimately if
you're using Python for example or if
using Scala you said was one of the
other options pretty much anything nice
okay yes so you can attach a kernel to
your notebooks and RAM whatever code is
there so yeah so you have the
description and you have the code the
code is what matters when you're
actually building the thing descriptions
perfect like definitely useful and you
could keep your notebooks in source
control or inside other stuff so people
can see what you've done but when it
comes to actually building a pipeline to
repeat this stuff and do it over and
over again then I think having the code
in real code files that can be called
externally in a in a kind of nice
repeatable way and can be tested
individually can be really really
valuable and maybe would be a nicer way
to go in my opinion I'm coming out at it
from a developer opinion as well so one
of the things you mentioned there was
testing testing a Cell if you've got a
notebook in one of those cells is
transforming a billion rows of data sets
yeah and yeah how do you test something
like that so well the first thing is if
you have that cell you could extract
what in those cell that you're within
that cell into a function or something
like that that you can
isolate sometimes the way that it's
written though it doesn't lend itself to
testability being able to extract that
stuff to say here is your input and give
me their output if that is a
encapsulated function much like we do in
software engineering
you can run tests against that in
custody encapsulated function create
your test dataset which maybe is 30 rows
and then push the data into it and pull
it out the other end maybe try putting
in some rows that are partly empty or
have negative values or just have
completely incorrect data to make sure
the thing doesn't explode at the other
end so having that stuff that's in a
Cell or that that series of functions
where you care about what the output is
given the input if that can be extracted
into its own function or module or
something that you can isolate and test
very much like you would test a class or
a function or something in your
application that's one way of doing it
but that does require you to not use
cheaper than notebooks as far as I can
tell
um yeah I think notebooks are really
good for exploring the data and yeah the
rest of it and the the sort of testing
you mentioned there maybe when you've
produced a model and and you want to put
stuff in and get specific types or
results back maybe something like that
it's a bit more testable yeah but
there's no reason why it can't be
checking in a super notebook or a data
Brooks notebook yeah and able to go
backwards and forwards on versions yes
see what you did yeah and you're right
like if that is an important part of the
process which led to the outcome that
you have to the thing that's in
production now having that in source
control is is great similarly you know
having documents in some kind of version
controlled system like your requirements
documents and stuff like that absolutely
you should be version controlling that
and again it might not be might not be
good as it might be I don't a say
SharePoint but it might be SharePoint
for example you know so same kind of
thing having that thing that's important
to your project having that in a version
controlled system can be really really
important
but when it comes to the actual
application that did it builds that
model and is you need to test and you
need to run through a pipeline I don't
have notable notebooks is the rightful
solution that said like right at the
start when I said these are the things
you need to care about languages and
tools if your data scientists use
Jupiter notebooks then don't tell them
not to use Jupiter notebooks just tell
them in order to enable this pipeline
this this way of doing stuff let's sit
down together and let's work out a way
of turning what you've got in the
notebook into something that we can
repeat later on like extracting those
functions extracting those modules and
doing that kind of work like part of
DevOps is is not one person or one team
telling another team how to do stuff
it's sitting down together and actually
working through these solutions together
so maybe the last like five minutes of
my discussion has been like no don't use
the tools that you want to use sorry I
want to back away from that use the
tools you want to use but you know sit
down and try and work out better ways of
you know having that lifecycle behave
nicely for everybody yeah yes
so do you have any recommendation for
any tool or idea that we can keep track
of different versions different versions
of data that's uh that's like the really
hard thing frankly so I've heard two
arguments for this one is you absolutely
need to keep versions of data that means
you need to either you need to have some
kind of strategy either use snapshot
your data on a regular basis so that you
can say at this particular date this was
the version of the data that we have and
that might be feasible for your
organization but if you're just out of
inch that of you know curiosity be the
azure DevOps product which is the other
thing that I talk about a lot they
collect telemetry on how people are
using the product and they collect I
think it's something like about a
petabyte a day of data just as the
telemetry are you gonna snapshot that
every day no you're really not going to
do that so that's just not feasible so
saying we need a versioned history of
all of the data is it's a tricky problem
to solve I don't know of any tools that
do that really nicely at the moment what
you could do though is snapshots or you
know snapshot the diffs I suppose is one
way of doing it so if you if you had
your data if you had your data and then
every time somebody did a write you
wrote the fact that there was a right at
that particular point then you're not
snapshotting you're just keeping a log
of all the changes that occurred and I
think lace you had a project that did
something really really similar lately
right yeah
hi I'm lace I'm actually part of
Microsoft and the commercial software
engineering yeah so we had a similar
product project which required basically
repeatability of a pipeline and your
data was constantly changing so we
essentially identified different types
of data one was the small data sets
where you can literally snapshot when
you need it and there were the
incremental data sets where all the all
the changes the data sets were
effectively inserts or writes in which
case and they were sequential writes in
which case you don't need the snapshot
because you just know with until which
point in time did you run your model and
you know you can reproduce your data set
and the third and trickiest data set was
where you have updates and deletes and
that's what Damon was saying around
actually just recording the change so
you have a change log over time so you
don't delete records you soft delete
them you update you don't really update
records you you just soft update them so
effectively every row is immutable and
you're just writing inserting your soft
deletes and updates and what we did is
we created a view of which basically
translates the most up-to-date view of
your data sets so as a person querying
the data I don't have to worry about you
know select update where is the soft and
what's a current view the data so that
was the probably the trickiest part so
we call them different Delta pipes
within data set so there's certain
different ways without actually
snapshotting a petabyte of data but the
third type is probably the trickiest one
yep yeah um the other argument I've
heard and this is obviously only
appropriate for some scenarios is don't
even worry about it
and then it's in that's quite often in
scenarios where you use that data to
create a predictive model and then you
have that model as an artifact you
always store how you got that model you
know you use the data at the time and
you might retrain it using up-to-date
data but you're never going to need to
retrain that thing based on old data so
you don't need to worry about it right
obviously only some scenarios
that's valid for but you may not even
want to keep old data you may want to
train the model and keep that old model
but don't worry about keeping the old
data so that's also a doing nothing is
also a solution it's an option yeah cool
I think we're towards the end of the
time my twitter handle as well by the
way if you are one of the data
scientists and you like everything this
guy said is crap right then I definitely
want to hear from you as well because as
I said I'm coming at this not from a
data science perspective from a
development perspective but I want to
make this the stuff that we're doing
work for both both sides so really like
talking about this stuff so hit me up
I'm especially on Twitter or email if
you want demo visa at Microsoft com will
get to me too awesome thank you very
much